justement parlant de cadeaux je suis
ravi d'être invitée comme tout invités
j'ai tenu moi tout particulièrement jean
bart un cadeau aussi attendre sa niche
avec
cindy sache-le alors je kiffe et sylvie
mais je te préfère ça
c'est bon je te préfère
savez on m'avait dit absolument passer
incognito chez
cindy tu peux mourir
j'attends j'entends un truc
je déteste le maracana est cindy déjà
ses magnifiques parce qu'en plus c'est
assorti a tenu
la baraque est passablement
choqué c'est bon je te kiffe
un amour
alors vous savez qu'un turc chèque de
paye que ce soit la traque est assez
mais je te le jure que c'est vrai mais
ça que mais c'est un coin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a un peu lutté mais qui tarde qui t'a
donné cette idée chez toi et bien sûr
ses passes tes veines non absolument pas
la faille dans une agence est non
seulement des plans dit est justement là
et avec plaisir sera l'occasion de vous
accueillir éventuellement match dijon
vannes
à pato mois dijon panaccio avec des miss
retraités attendent miss france
considère que c'est fait c'est vrai
eh ben on croyait sine die
animation du système
on retrouve les singles en prime time
tous les jours
et dans le groupe canal+ à cindy
retrouver cindy dans tout le groupe
canal
mais s'il juge que la saillie tech miss
france 2005 tu es magnifique tu es
vraiment là président qu'il nous fallait
non mais j'aimais beaucoup je ne crache
pas dans la soupe vous adorez c'est
beaucoup si vous ne rateriez c'est mais
cindy alors là je vois
mes chine dit ça y est pour moi je te
dise on t'attendait le roi est mort vive
le roi
[Applaudissements]